These image based visual control strategies
have got two important requirements.
One is to reliably find the points on the
target object, and by reliably means every
single frame: as the object is moving or the
camera is moving, we need to be able to identify
the same points on the target object.
The second problem is to determine which point
is which. This is what we call the correspondence
problem. So, in the case of our triangular
target before, we need to determine which
point in the current view corresponds to which
point in the desired view.
Considering now the first problem: how do
we reliably find points on the target object.
Once upon a time this was done by creating
artificial scenes that have got very high
contrasts. So here are two examples from my
PhD research back in the 1990s, and what I
had was very much a black background and a
white object. So we could use very simple
thresholding techniques and binary vision
processing techniques, which were very very
fast, in order to identify the object. But
this is, clearly, very unrealistic.
Another approach is to introduce something
into the scene which has got a distinctive
color. We have talked before about how this
mobile robot could navigate with respect to
an orange traffic cone. The image on the right
shows our landing target for an indoor flying
robot. It could see this configuration of
four yellow targets, identify the centroid
of those, and land on them.
Another way we can make the problem easy is
to make the target something that's very bright;
something that actually emits light. So perhaps
we could put a colored LED on the object in
the scene, and the robot's vision system can
identify that particular patch of very bright
color. By using the bright color it makes
it easier to segment.
Another approach is to put some kind of pattern
on the object, and here we see a number of
patterns that are used for localisation. In
the middle we have what we call a self-similar
landmark, and you can see that the computer
vision algorithm is able to very, very robustly
determine the position of the centres of those
three landmarks, almost irrespective of the
pose of the sheet, even if the targets are
somewhat obscured. On the left we see some
related landmarks, this time using vertical
lines rather than circles, which are used
in that particular robot to identify the location of the crucible to the robot so it can pick it up.
We can also use QR code as shown here on the
right. We can compute centroid of the QR code,
it’s a very unique pattern, but the QR code
also contains a number of bytes of information.
Often times these are used to encode URLs
in advertising. So this QR code has got a
position but it's also got some information
associated with it.
Related to QR codes is another type of code
called an AR code or an augmented reality
code, and they can be used to label objects
in a three-dimensional world.